Salut, aujourd'hui,
je vais faire une expérience
particulièrement intéressante
sur la thématique de l'alcool.
Il y aura avec moi
Audrey Pirault, Ludovic B,
Fannyfique et Nino Arial.
Durant une semaine,
je leur ai demandé
quelque chose de simple,
mais qu'ils n'ont pourtant jamais fait
au cours de leur vie.
C'est-à-dire noter sur un papier
chaque verre d'alcool qu'ils ont consommé.
Évidemment, pour que
cette expérience fonctionne,
ils ne devaient pas augmenter
ou diminuer leur consommation naturelle.
Merci d'ailleurs à Alcool Info Service
qui nous permet de réaliser cette vidéo.
La première étape, c'est que mes invités
vont, pour la première fois de leur vie,
voir devant eux en une seule fois,
en un seul coup,
tous les verres d'alcool
qu'ils ont consommés en une semaine
et je peux vous dire
que ça peut surprendre.
On va ensuite savoir comment et pourquoi
chacun de ces verres a été consommé
et vous allez voir que les réponses
sont parfois surprenantes.
Petite précision évidemment,
personne n'est là pour se juger
ou pour juger les autres.
C'est fait en toute bienveillance.
Il s'agit vraiment d'une expérience
passionnante pour essayer de comprendre
nos consommations et aussi, dans un sens,
pour mieux comprendre la relation
entre nos cerveaux, l'alcool
et notre manière d'en boire.
Ça va être vraiment passionnant
et ça commence maintenant.
Et c'est le moment d'accueillir nos
quatre invités Audrey Pirault, Ludovic B,
Parce que tu as une lettre en nom de famille.
Nino Arial et Fannyfique.
- Bonjour
Déjà, en vrai, merci d'être là.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir
assuré cette semaine en jouant le jeu.
On commence par toi Audrey
Est-ce que tu peux essayer
de te remémorer tous les verres
que tu as bus cette semaine?
Il faut savoir que c'était
la semaine de mon anniversaire.
- Donc on voit des gens.
- Donc je n'ai vu personne.
- D'accord.
- Donc je n'ai vu vraiment personne.
- Rapport à la situation...
- De ta vie éclatée.
- De ma vie.
C’est ça, non mais c’est ça.
Du coup, lundi, rien.
Le mardi., un verre.
Le mercredi, boum ! J’enchaine.
Deux petits cocktails, Fabien.
Le jeudi, rien. Le vendredi...
Bain, soin du visage, mousse, apéritif.
Et là, je me suis ouvert
une petite bière.
- Ok
- Le samedi,
certainement un verre de vin
et le dimanche, mimosa le matin.
- Ok, au brunch.
- Au brunch du matin.
- D'accord. Nino Arial.
- Ouais.
Alors, lundi niet.
Mardi, bière.
- Ok
- Je pense, deux-trois bières.
Mercredi et jeudi, rien.
- Ok
- Et c'est vendredi que vraiment, là...
- Ça bascule.
Ce pote qui a un bar me dit :
"Ben viens, on va passer un moment ensemble."
J'ai pris une bière
et j'ai commencé à partir.
- On dirait que t'es au tribunal.
Mais parce qu’en fait,
j'avais oublié mon manteau.
Du coup, je suis revenu prendre
une deuxième bière, ça c'est sûr.
Et puis une troisième.
Et c'est là qu'après,
ça a été une soirée complexe.
Attends, tu sais quoi ?
Ça m'intéresse de dire, ne détaille
plus cette soirée là,
combien tu penses
avoir bu de verres sur cette soirée ?
Je ne ferai pas un tout pile, c'est certain.
Je ne suis pas Nagui.
Je dirais une vingtaine.
Donc ce qui nous ferait
23 verres sur la soirée, sur la semaine.
Après, j'ai fait encore juste une bière
ou deux et c'était terminé.
Fannyfique, lundi, combien de verres
d'alcool ou de cubi ?
- Petite soirée entre potes.
J'ai commencé au cidre.
Je pense que j'ai bu, je ne sais pas,
trois-quatre verres de cidre.
Ensuite, je dirais oui, une ou deux bières
et à la fin, petite
liqueur québécoise.
Le lendemain, j'ai terminé
une bouteille de vin
que j'avais ouverte,
dont personne ne voulait.
Je pense que j'ai bu deux-trois verres
dans cette bouteille-là.
Ouais, le week-end...
Le mardi soir, c'est le week-end après ?
Après j'ai pas bu.
Mercredi, jeudi, vendredi, rien.
Mais du coup, moi je bois
rarement de l'alcool toute seule,
c'est plus quand
j'ai des gens à l'occasion.
- Comme ta maman ?
Absolument. Et du coup, avec elle,
quand elle est venue le week end,
Petit apéro, une ou deux bières, petit cocktail.
Et c'est tout, je crois, ah non !
Un rhum arrangé.
Et allez, comme la mémoire
lui revient
Ludo ?
Quelle est ta semaine ?
Le lundi, mardi, mercredi,
j'ai bu une bière chaque jour,
voilà.
- Très réglé quoi.
- Ouais, le soir 19h, petite bière
Vendredi, j'avais une soirée,
j'ai dû boire deux verres de vin,
deux mojitos et deux shooters.
D’accord, six verres.
Ça me suffait d’ailleurs,
j’ai pas bu plus
C’est marrant parce que ça, ça marche
avec n'importe quel chiffre.
J'ai bu vingt-sept verres.
Ça marche peu importe le nombre
Ça me va nickel.
Et après, j'ai pas bu le samedi.
Mais j'ai bu le dimanche.
Parce que le dimanche
J'avais un repas de famille
et j'ai dû boire quatre verres de vin
Vous allez découvrir tous les verres
que vous avez consommés.
Chacun et chacune en une semaine.
Je vous laisse vous
retourner pour découvrir
votre consommation de la semaine
en une seule fois, allez-y retournez-vous
et voici la consommation de Fannyfique
et la consommation de Nino.
Ici, c'est toi Ludo, ça te fait quoi
de voir tout ce que tu as consommé
dans la semaine, en une seule fois ?
C'est vrai que là, en une fois,
ça fait beaucoup.
- Oui
- Typiquement, je ne le boirais pas.
Et toi Audrey, qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Je trouve que ça va. De toute façon
dans ma personnalité,
je modère les choses en général.
Après, j'aurais pu aussi
ne pas du tout boire d'alcool.
Ce qui me fait bizarre,
c'est en termes de quantité.
Tout est énorme alors que toi
tu en as plein,
mais plein de petits.
Je suis happée par le volume.
- Je comprends.
- De tout ce que j'ai bu.
Il y en a pas mal.
Tu es en train de préparer le terrain
pour quand on en viendra à toi.
Je me rends compte
que je bois des petits verres moi
par rapport elle.
Elle, elle se met des grandes pintes.
Moi, je fais des petits trucs, non,
je revois ma soirée quoi, et je me dis
que j'ai vraiment passé une soirée
- À boire.
- À boire, oui.
Moi, ce que je me dis, c'est que tu abordes
un point qui est très intéressant.
C'est le côté rituel, un peu automatisme.
Par exemple, on l'a sur cette ligne-là
où tu nous disais :
“Ben en fait la bière, c'est un rituel le soir.”
- Je pourrais boire autre chose.
Ça m'irait très bien.
Je me dis : "Allez tiens,
19h, tiens, c'est l'heure de ma bière."
C'est un automatisme.
Et toi, rappelle-moi
les moments de consommation?
Ah non, il y avait un petit bain rituel.
- Ah oui !
C'est de là qu'elle vient cette bière.
- Oui.
Et du coup est-ce que tu penses
que ton bain serait moins relaxant avec ?
Je décorrèle complètement
le fait de boire de l'alcool et soit
de passer un bon moment, soit d'être plus relaxée.
J'ai conscience que c'est moi
qui détermine l’état,
et pas ce que je bois qui détermine mon état.
C'est vrai, mais ce n'est pas forcément
un chemin mental qu'on fait
tous comme ça, spontanément.
Non mais surtout selon l'âge
que tu as aussi.
Parce que je te dis ça aujourd'hui.
Mais il y a quelques années,
j'aurais pu aussi avoir un autre discours.
Est-ce que vous saviez
qu'il y a des repères
de consommation d'alcool
pour limiter les risques sur notre santé ?
En vrai, ces repères sont intéressants.
Ils sont de dix unités
d'alcool par semaine,
sachant qu'il faut
qu'il n'y en ait pas plus de deux par jour
et donc forcément des jours
où on ne boit pas du tout.
Toi, t'as cramé les 10.
Je mets un point d'honneur,
tu vois, qu’il n'est pas, enfin,
que ce ne soit pas
le verre de tous les soirs, etc.
Par contre, le problème, c'est qu'à l'inverse,
du coup, quand j'y vais, ben j'y vais.
J'ai une consommation
en dents de scie un peu,
mais alors la légende du verre
de vin rouge qui est bon pour la santé.
Du coup, t'as répondu...
- C'est une légende.
- ...toi même à ta question.
- Je me disais bien aussi.
Les vieux qui disent ça
ils n'ont plus de dents.
Et c'est vrai que l'on connait
très mal l'alcool.
Pire. On connaît, par contre,
plein d'astuces dessus,
mais qui sont complètement fausses.
Alors, faisons ensemble un petit tour
des trois grosses idées reçues à ce sujet.
Fun fact. D'ailleurs, moi,
quand j'étais plus jeune,
j'ai aussi cru à chacune d'entre elles
puisque tout le monde
autour de moi disait ça.
Idée reçue numéro une.
“Hé si t'as froid, tu bois un coup hein.”
“Ça réchauffe.”
Alors non.
La première chose que fait l'alcool
sur le corps, c'est justement l'inverse.
C'est de baisser sa température interne.
Alors, pourquoi on croit l'inverse ?
Eh bien, une fois dans le sang,
l'alcool dilate les vaisseaux sanguins
qui se trouvent juste en haut, à proximité
de la peau, ce qui donne une sensation,
presque une illusion de chaleur,
mais qui est fausse, car la température
interne du corps ne s'élève pas.
Idée reçue numéro 2
“Ouais ben au moins,
moi j'ai bu qu'un seul verre de vin.”
“C'est pas comme si on avait pris un verre
avec un alcool fort.”
Peu importe le nom de votre boisson,
c'est la même molécule qu'on retrouve.
Voici d'ailleurs
le tableau des équivalences.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on voit ?
On y voit entre autres qu'un verre de vin,
un apéritif anisé
ou une boisson un peu forte,
ou encore un demi de bière ou encore
un vin pétillant contiennent tous
la même quantité d'alcool.
Idée reçue numéro 3
“Une bonne bière quand même hein,
ça désaltère.”
Alors écoutez, que ce soit une bière
ou un autre verre d’alcool
vous serez au contraire
déshydratés à chaque fois.
L'éthanol, qui est présent
dans tous les verres alcoolisés,
amène le corps à éliminer son eau.
D'où le fait que vous ayez beaucoup envie
d'aller aux toilettes.
D'ailleurs, ce que l'on appelle
la gueule de bois est entre autres due
à cette déshydratation.
Alors là, je vais vous demander
de faire un exercice un peu particulier.
Je vais vous demander d'enlever des verres
et de vous dire quels verres vraiment
objectivement...
- Ne servent à rien.
j'aurais pu me passer, me servent à rien
ou j'aurais pu remplacer
par un verre d'eau.
On commence par toi, Ludo,
J'ai déjà ma petite idée,
moi déjà, les 3 bières,
en fait, c'est pas le côté alcool
qui m'intéresse là dedans.
Ça pourrait très bien
ne pas être de l'alcool.
Ça je me ferai une menthe à l'eau à la place
et ça marche très bien.
- Ok.
- Ça me fait mon repère.
Donc là, on commence
ta semaine avec...
- Avec la soirée FIFA.
mais là, je peux très bien
toutes les enlever.
- Ah ouais ? Carrément !
- Mais parce que j'aime pas la bière.
- Ah c'est drôle et tu bois quand même des bières,
du coup lors de cette soirée.
C'est incroyable !
- Parce que ton pote il arrive
et il prend deux bières dans le frigo
il l'ouvre, paf, il te la donne,
tu vois ?
Je préférerais un soda,
mais comme il ouvre la bière,
Ben tu dis pas non.
Tu dis ok.
On voit la pression sociale tu sais,
le regard de l'autre.
Tu te dis : "Non, mais il va penser quoi de moi."
- Je te mets une bière.
- En plus ça va le soûler...
- Nan, mets moi une grenadine.
- J'ai pas envie de m'expliquer
pendant 3 heures...
- Exactement, exactement.
Donc toi, tu as une bonne conscience
de ce que tu as consommé.
Est-ce que tu as
une bonne conscience aussi
de pourquoi tu consommes
ces verres d'alcool ?
C'est pas des automatismes,
parce que je peux avoir des comportements
qui sont addictifs
et je suis très vigilante à ça.
Donc quand je consomme de l'alcool,
j'ai conscience du fait que tu peux tomber
dans un schéma avec l'alcool.
Que ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'anodin, c'est pas un produit anodin.
C'est pas anodin.
Donc, ce premier cocktail
Donc, ce premier cocktail,
il est conservé, celui du lendemain,
effectivement, je pourrais en retirer un
parce qu'il est bu
sous l'impulsion du premier.
C'est une envie, très claire,
mais c'est vrai que dans l'idée,
on pourrait dire mais en fait, en vrai,
si un t'a suffi la veille,
un te suffit le jour même.
- Alors Fanny.
- Ouais ?
- On refait ta semaine.
- Absolument.
Qu'est-ce que tu gardes ?
Qu'est-ce que tu ne gardes pas ?
Ben, en fait, moi,
ça va être aussi facile.
J'ai l'impression
que si je fais une soirée où je bois
je me dis bon ben,
vu que je vais boire ce soir,
- J'ouvre les vannes.
- Voilà j'ouvre les vannes.
Et donc du coup, en fait, en vrai...
Je pourrais n'en prendre
que un de chaque, tu vois.
J'ai bu trois verres de cidre.
En vrai j'aurais pu en boire
qu'un, parce qu'en fait, après,
je remplis mon verre.
- Et tu ne te prives pas en faisant ça ?
- Non, non pas du tout.
Et il y a ce truc,
un peu de pudeur aussi,
genre quand t'es en soirée,
avec des gens que tu connais pas,
t'es protégé par ton verre. Moi, je suis la
meuf qui traine près du buffet.
- Physiquement parlant.
Ouais ouais, mais moi toujours.
Je ne peux pas
faire une soirée sans être protégée,
soit par un petit truc que je bouffe,
soit par mon verre.
Mais clairement j'ai pris deux shooters.
Moi, je les enlève.
- J'aime pas ces trucs, comment tu fais pour aimer ça ?
- Ben justement, le pire, c'est que j'aime pas.
Il y en a un qui a dit :
"Allez, on fait les shooters."
Il a commencé à servir tout le monde,
et en fait j'ai suivi le groupe.
- Pression sociale ?
- Ouais je n'avais pas envie.
- Elle existe vraiment cette pression sociale
dans notre consommation en fait.
Ce qui fait qu'il te resterait cinq verres
d'alcool sur ta semaine et là,
on est largement d’ailleurs en dessous des repères.
C'est intéressant de se dire
que quand on prend
encore une fois sans se culpabiliser
de quoi que ce soit,
juste qu'on essaie de prendre conscience
de sa propre consommation,
au final, je n’ai que cinq unités
- Le pire, c’est que je me prive de rien dans tout ça
Ben oui, c'est ça.
C’est tout l'intérêt de l'exercice.
Vous le voyez, chacun a fait des efforts
incroyables, mais reste encore légèrement
au-dessus des repères.
Par exemple, Audrey a supprimé
un de ses verres,
mais il y a toujours une journée
où elle boit plus de deux unités d'alcool.
Fanny en a aussi enlevé quelques-uns.
Bravo à elle.
Pourtant, la journée à quatre unités
l'empêche de valider ce repère.
Enfin, Nino a été le plus spectaculaire
dans l'annulation de ses verres,
même s'il reste un peu au-dessus.
Allez, il y est presque, bravo.
Parce qu'il y aussi un rapport avec l'alcool
qui est ce que tu renvoies à l'autre
Demain, je vais boire un verre
avec un pote, je vais prendre une bière,
je vais boire un verre avec une meuf, un date,
je vais prendre un verre de vin blanc,
je vais boire un verre avec mes parents,
je vais prendre un soda.
Le truc qu'on pourra retenir,
c'est l'automatisme du quotidien
du cerveau,
de la routine, de la routine sociale
qui fait que ce nombre de verres d'alcool,
alors que l'alcool,
ce n'est pas quelque chose à diaboliser,
ce n'est pas le but de cette vidéo,
mais par contre, ce n'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin en fait l’alcool.
Et donc, en cassant
les automatismes de consommation,
on prend du recul et on peut se dire :
“Ah ok, c'est comme ça que je consomme.
Peut-être que je pourrais
consommer différemment.”
Après tout ces verres éliminés,
on pourrait quand même se demander pourquoi
ils ont été consommés si facilement.
La réponse est majoritairement
la pression sociale, vous l'avez vu.
Soyons lucides, il est très compliqué
de refuser un verre,
surtout quand on a l'impression
de se faire juger et qu'en plus,
on se prend vite une petite réflexion
pas souvent agréable.
C'est très courant d'entendre un...
“Ouais, pourquoi ?
T'es enceinte ?”
Ou encore...
“Désolé, mais je trinque pas avec de l'eau, non.”
Ou encore le fameux :
"Oh, fais pas ton relou, bois un vrai truc".
ou un : "Ah, t'as un problème
avec l'alcool toi ?"
ou encore même le naïf
"Pourquoi ? C'est pas toi qui conduis pourtant."
Donnons le choix de la boisson
pour inciter ceux qui ne veulent pas
de verres ou d'un autre verre
à prendre autre chose
qu'un verre d'eau, même si, au demeurant,
il n'y a pas mieux pour s'hydrater.
La bonne parade pour les petites phrases
sur le fait de ne pas prendre un verre d’alcool,
c'est d'abord
de ne pas s'excuser.
Personnellement,
je ne bois pas souvent d'alcool
et quand on me propose un verre
et qu'on me demande pourquoi je ne veux pas
le boire, je réponds les phrases suivantes :
"J'en ai pas envie, tout simplement."
Vous avez vu le tout simplement.
C'est imparable et en plus,
c'est loin d'être sec comme réponse.
Une autre réponse peut être :
"Non, j'ai plutôt soif.
Je vais plutôt prendre un vrai verre."
J'adore dire un vrai verre
pour parler d'autre chose que de l'alcool.
De la même manière,
n'hésitez pas à intervenir en toute bienveillance
pour aussi appuyer
positivement quelqu'un qui refuse
un verre, mais à qui on fait une remarque.
C'est important de casser le rituel
de la consommation d'alcool automatique
et ça, ça se joue en collectif.
Et encore une fois, ne vous sentez pas
obligés et encore moins désolés de refuser.
Vous avez encore le droit de décider
de ce qui rentre dans votre organisme.
Merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu'au bout.
Et là, je prends pas trop de risques,
vraiment, parce que s'ils sont encore là,
c'est qu'ils sont jusqu'au bout,
- Tout à fait.
- C'est un truc de mentaliste.
- Pas mal.
- C'est fort ça.
Mais en vrai j'espère que le fait d'avoir
vécu ça, pour vous comme pour nous,
ça va nous permettre de nous aider
peut-être à laisser un peu moins
son cerveau en mode automatique
de se poser pour se dire.
Tiens, est-ce que j'ai vraiment
conscience de telle décision
ou telle décision
que je suis en train de prendre ?
Ou est-ce qu'elle se fait
un petit peu sans moi ?
J'ai envie de vous proposer de fêter
cette fin de tournage
avec quelques jus
et quelques cocktails,
mais le tout sans alcool
parce que en fait, c'est très bon.
Et puis ça désaltère.
Donc ça fait plaisir.
- Est-ce que je peux prendre juste de l'eau ?
- SI t'as juste soif, il vaut mieux prendre
que de l'eau.
C'était un plaisir de  vous avoir.
- Merci Fabien.
- Vous êtes un peu loin et les tchin tchin
pour les micros c'est pas ouf.
Alors merci !
- Merci beaucoup.
J'allais le faire moi.
Tiens, dans les yeux !
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Je serais très curieux
qu'on échange dans les commentaires
sur ce que vous a inspiré
le fait de prendre conscience
de sa propre consommation.
Attention, on fait ça sans pression.
D'ailleurs, n'oubliez pas
de liker cette video
que je vous invite
à partager autour de vous.
Merci également à Santé publique France
de m'avoir permis de réaliser ce format.
Cette expérience, cette vidéo.
et merci également à mes quatre invités
d'avoir participé.
Comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
vous trouverez leur chaîne, leur Insta,
ce genre de détails dans la description.
Sinon, je m'appelle toujours
Fabien Olicard. Ça n'a pas changé.
Vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant ici.
C'est gratuit et à côté, vous trouverez
deux autres vidéos sur le cerveau,
la matière grise,
sur les supers pouvoirs qu'on a ici
et une autre sur les biais cognitifs.
Prenez soin de vous ! À très bientôt ciao !